alors l'échographie donc c'est une
technique qui fait appel aux ultrason et
on réalise ce qu'on appelle un balayage
sur l'ensemble de l'herme mère un camion
itinérant pour aider à sauver des vies
depuis le 2 octobre dernier le mamau
solidaire sillonne l'Île-de-France pour
permettre de réaliser des mammographies
contre le cancer du sein ce mardi le
dispositif était au pied du château de
Buc objectif permettre en priorité aux
patientes sorties du circuit de
dépistage de réaliser leur examen au
plus près de leur domicile la plupart de
femmes hésitent parce que euh elles ont
peur du résultat c'est principalement
c'est la peur du résultat et ensuite il
paraît que pour certaines femmes la
mammographie elle elle fait mal donc
pourtant c'est un examen qui ne dure pas
plus de de d'une dizaine de minutes si
ce cancer est le plus fréquent chez la
femme le nombre de dépistage a pourtant
diminué de 9,5 % en 10ant détecter
suffisamment tôt cette pathologie
peut-être guérie dans 90 % des cas le
mameau solidaire vise à faire tomber
certaines barrières pour certaines
femmes c'est certain que ça lève des
obstacles soit de matériel de de
proximité de de de déplacement difficile
soit des obstacles psychologique parce
que pour le dépistage en fait qui
parfois il suffit d'un déclic pour
inciter une patiente à prendre
rendez-vous alors qu'elle aurait hésité
à passer la porte d'un cabinet de
radiologie de ville en octobre 2022 le
camion francilien a accueilli 265
personnes ce matin-là Séverine a réalisé
sa mamographie suite à la campagne de
communication octobre rose je suis venue
parce que en fait j'ai des antécédents
de personnes qui ont déjà eu aussi des
cancers du sein donc ça m'a mobilisé je
sais l'importance de se faire dépister
très tôt accessible entre 50 et 74 ans
ce service gratuit nécessite une
inscription par téléphone ce mercredi 11
octobre le mamot solidaire s'arrêtera
sur le parking de la mairie de trappe
entre 9h et
18h